I was with the cast of Beverly Hills
90210 proved they're just as close as
ever attending a reunion over the
weekend at rewind con in Bloomingdale
Illinois we shared not go away simply
because we did Jennie Garth Luke Perry
Jason Priestley and Tori Spelling were
all there among others but noticeably
absent was star XI and Endora T who
couldn't make it due to breast cancer
treatments the group didn't waste the
opportunity to sing her praises perry
said in part quote none of us are up
here today without Shannon she's been
through a lot
she taught me a lot I'm glad she was my
scene partner she was great at what she
did in the character with me go look
back years from now and I'll just be a
girl you knew in high school well you
know you want Brett after Jennie Garth
showed her support for Shannon on
Instagram too she posted this photo that
says fight like a brenda and candidly
wrote in the caption strongest lady I've
ever known then and now I used to be
threatened by your spirit now I'm in awe
of it I missed you I missed you too
you